in the beatles you were closest to john
lennon that's you know well
it depends on the day yeah you know
george was my great friend
and paul was my friend
we went round actually you know we
shared a room we only ever had two rooms
while we were touring and we were all
slept with each other not literally
right
no but but but i would think in those
early days sharing rooms together those
were the days that you look back on and
go that was fantastic we were a very
close band we only had ever had one
limousine to take us around yeah we
didn't have our own you know a lot of
english bands started doing that yeah
what do you think cream and that they'd
be in different hotels and drive to the
gig and just play i know we were with
each other that's how we knew each other
and we were in germany you know we
worked very hard and at one point
rory and hurricanes and the beatles we
were doing 12 hours a night on the
weekend
that's a lot of plan and don't you think
that's exactly why the beatles became so
great and sustained that amount of hits
and everything because you it was like a
secret language you were almost speaking
you become brothers we do and you know
it doesn't matter we're like brothers we
have rows we have little arguments
discussions
as soon as you heard the count in we all
gave our all right i'm always always
proud of that i well offered because two
of our members aren't here and well
speaking was great
a lot of good music the assassination of
john lennon which still pains me to this
day and i'm yeah i'm a fan it was so
hard but but you know your reaction was
to immediately drop everything and fly
to new york and be with yoko um yeah
which i think is such a loving just said
oh you play with sean yeah cause she was
messed up too you know i mean it was i
didn't it was like mad
and we were in the bahamas and uh
francesca my stepdaughter she called
said something's happened to to john
what's happened to john and then we
heard and so we got on a plane and we
just flew to new york we didn't know
what we could do we just knew we had to
go right it was the right thing to do
well it was what we did and when you got
there the way you comforted her was to
take care of sean well that's what we
did at the end right you know